Let's talk through some examples
of predicting numeric and
non-numeric outcomes.
We'll use these examples
throughout the rest of the lesson.
Let's use three examples,
a tricycle manufacturer,
a marketing organization, and a bank.
For our first example, imagine that
a manufacturer wants to use historical
production data to know how many
tricycles they'll need to produce
over the next six months,
to meet expected demand.
Since the outcome the manufacturer
wants to predict is a number,
then the target variable is numeric.
Therefore, they would use a numeric, or
regression, model to solve this problem.
For our second example, Hot and
Fresh Pizza wants to use sales data from
their existing stores, and respective
demographic data around those stores,
to predict how many pizzas they'll
sell at their new store location.
Since the outcome that Hot and
Fresh pizza is trying to predict
is the number of pizzas,
then the target variable is numeric, and
they would use a numeric, or regression,
model to solve this problem.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And for our third example, a bank wants
to use historical data of their clients
to predict whether a new customer will
default on a loan, always pay on time,
or sometimes pay.
Since the outcome the bank is trying
to predict is a category that the new
customer will fall into, they would
use non-numeric, or classification,
models to solve this problem.